TREVOR JOHNS: Hello, and welcome
to Dear Android, the
show previously known
as Android
Developer Office Hours.
We got a bit tired of developers
always trying to
show us up by asking us a
question that we couldn't
answer every week.
So we decided to try new
format for a change.
We'll be selecting the best
Android application
development questions from
across the internet, including
Google+, and answering them
for you here on YouTube.
If you're watching this live,
which is every Wednesday at
2:00 PM Pacific, we'll be
hanging around for a few
minutes after each episode to
answer any questions about the
current episode.
So with that out of the way,
let's go ahead and move on to
this week's question, which
comes from Dancio on Stack
Overflow, who's a user
from Poland.
He asks, if I have a custom
service that I'm broadcasting
via Bonjour, and that I'd like
to either broadcast or
discover using wi-fi
or Bluetooth, is
this possible on Android?
To answer this question, we
have Alex Lucas, who is a
member of our Android developer
relations team, who
wrote many of the docs about
both network service discovery
and wi-fi on our developers
site.
Alex, could you help us
answer this question?
ALEX LUCAS: Absolutely.
So to break the question into
two sub-parts, will
Bonjour-like services work
on Bluetooth and will
they work on wi-fi?
The answer is, yes on wi-fi,
no on Bluetooth.
Thank you for tuning in.
That's our show.
TREVOR JOHNS: See you, Alex.
ALEX LUCAS: Bye.
So we should actually probably
answer this question in a
little bit more detail.
To start with the Bluetooth
part, Bluetooth is a really
great protocol for lots of
device to device applications,
like streaming music
or communicating
with heart-rate monitors.
But on Android, it does not
actually support TCP.
So what that means is you cannot
create a TCP socket and
connect to it over Bluetooth
to other devices.
Because network service
discovery, or at least the
Android implementation of
network service discovery run
over TCP, this creates a
fundamental incompatibility
between Bluetooth and TCP.
That said, it does actually
work over wi-fi.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
So before we go into a bit more
detail, let's give a bit
of background about what
exactly what NSD is.
So NSD is network service
discovery, which is Android's
implementation of multicast
DNS, using the DNS service
discovery protocol.
And what this does is it
allows applications to
broadcast to their existence
on the local network, along
with connection details for that
application to any other
devices in the same proximity,
which would be any other
devices, again, on the
same local network.
So this is useful for things
like social applications,
games, or even networks
services like
printers or web servers.
So that way you can find out
what devices are nearby.
ALEX LUCAS: When NSD broadcasts
this information
over the network, there's four
fundamental pieces of
information it's going
to send over.
One of them is the device
identifier.
The device identifier is often
going to be either the user's
name or the device host name.
Another item is going to
be the service name.
The service name is often going
to be the name of the
application.
For instance, if you have a
game called Replica Island
that you want to play with other
users over the network,
and Replica Island has network
service discovery built in,
the service name is probably
going to be something like
Replica Island.
Another item is going to be the
host address, which you
don't actually have to enter
yourself at runtime.
Android will just figure that
out for you and send that
along and the NSD packets.
The final item is going
to be the port.
And I wanted to make a special
note about the port, which is
that for mobile applications,
the easiest thing to do when
you're designing the game or
the application, is not
actually to pick your own
port at runtime or
hard code one in.
What you want to do is get
a server socket and
set it to port zero.
And what that's going to do is
it's going to tell the Android
framework, just give me whatever
port is available on
the system.
When the server socket returns
the port number to you, you
then enter that port number
into the network services
discovery broadcast.
The handy thing about this is
that if you, for instance, had
decided that you wanted port 53
to be one your application
runs on, and some other
application developer decided
that they wanted port 53 to be
the one that their application
runs on, there would never
be a conflict.
And there would never be an
issue where the user had to
choose between your application
or someone else's
application running
at any given time.
TREVOR JOHNS: Right,
that's a nice fact.
It means if you don't have to
request or reserve to port
from the IANA.
Now you do still have to go
and register your service
name, but it's as simple
as just filling
out a simple form.
And the chances of there being
a conflict are pretty much
nonexistent.
ALEX LUCAS: Yeah, very small.
You don't actually need the
IANA reservation for when
you're doing internal testing.
But as soon as you let your
application out onto the
internet to roam free, it's
a really good idea to get
registered.
TREVOR JOHNS: Yeah, it's
just good practice.
All right, now we talked a bit
earlier about Bluetooth.
And even though you can't use
NSD on Bluetooth , there's
another answer we want to give
you, a better answer.
And that's called
Wi-Fi Direct.
Wi-Fi Direct is a peer-to-peer
version of wi-fi.
So it lets devices communicate
with one another without
having to go through
an access point.
This provides many of the same
benefits as Bluetooth,
device-device connections, but
with the advantages of wi-fi,
which means increased speed
and increased range.
This is available on devices
running Android 4 or above.
That's Honeycomb.
And if you happen to be running
Android 4.1, Jelly
Bean, you also get service
discovery.
Now unlike the traditional
case of network service
discovery, which we just
addressed, Wi-Fi Direct
service discovery will work even
when you're not connected
to a network.
So think about that
for a second.
Devices running your application
nearby can be
detected, even if they're
not connected to the
same network as you.
That's pretty cool.
ALEX LUCAS: What my favorite
thing about that-- what that
basically means, is if you're in
a movie theater waiting for
the previews to start.
Let's say, you've gone to
midnight showing or
something like that.
You have an hour to kill.
You can open up the application
and see who else
in the theater or in line is
playing the same game you are
and connect to them and
play a game, having no
idea who they are.
TREVOR JOHNS: It gives you
physical proximity.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
Physical proximity, which is
awesome, because you know that
the movie theater's not going to
have a wi-fi network there.
They're probably--
a lot of them these days
actually, are designed to
block incoming calls and
signals and stuff.
TREVOR JOHNS: Please don't use
that as an excuse to play the
game during the movie.
ALEX LUCAS: Right.
Don't play during the movie.
There's lots of helpful previews
that tell you that's
just a bad idea.
It's rude.
There'd be a bright screen
in front of the
people behind you.
And we're not suggesting that.
But when you have time to kill
in line, or before the
previews, knock yourself out.
Now we do want to point out that
it's still important to
implement network services
discovery for when you're
connected to a network.
There's a couple reasons
for this.
One of them is that Wi-Fi Direct
is not going to work at
all when you are connected to a
network, because of the way
the underlying technology
works.
You're either connected to a
network or you're surfing
around for Wi-Fi
Direct devices.
The other item is that there
are a lot of services and
hardware that broadcast services
that are designed to
be discovered on a network.
Examples of this are network
cameras and network printers.
Most companies will not set up
their network printers to be
Wi-Fi Direct accessible.
Because that means anyone who
was within and physical
proximity, who didn't
necessarily have permission to
use that printer, could print
out whatever they wanted.
So being on the network and
requiring the user to be on
the network provides a sort of
permission system or just a
small area of security.
So really your best option
is to implement both
Wi-Fi Direct and NSD.
And that way, your application
will have the best of both
worlds and increase the chances
of your users being
able to connect to each other,
no matter what circumstance.
In order to use Wi-Fi Direct
service discovery, the
necessary class that you'll
want to use is wi-fi P2P
manager, which provides an
implementation of DNS-SD
similar to the way standard
NSD does.
For more information about how
to actually implement network
service discovery and service
discovery over Wi-Fi Direct,
we have a training class
available at
developer.android.com/training.
And we really recommend
you go there and
read through the tutorial.
We also provide some
sample code.
And it walks you through a real
world example of how to
implement this functionality in
a preexisting application.
TREVOR JOHNS: And if you have
any questions about either NSD
or Wi-Fi Direct, join us via
Hangout after the live
broadcast, where we'll be able
to help answer those
questions for you.
And if you have any questions
for next week's broadcast,
post them to Stack Overflow or
send them to us via Android
Developers at Google+, and we'll
pick the best of them
for next week's broadcast.
And with that, we'll see
you all next week.
Thanks for joining us.
ALEX LUCAS: Bye guys.